lorsqu'il évoque les conditions du
contrôle judiciaire de son client il
parle d' aberration
à la sortie de l'audience l'avocat de
marcel jacob veut encore croire que la
justice acceptera de le modifier et que
le grand oncle du petit grégory pourra
rentrer chez lui
les arguments ils sont simples le fait
que marcel jacob vivent là où il est
actuellement ou chez lui ça ne change
pour l'accusation et pour la justice
rien pour lui c'est un pas de géant
c'est à dire qu'il n'en peut plus il
faut qu'il rentre chez lui c'est
aujourd'hui une question de survie est
gelée plaidé en demandant à la justice
de faire pour une fois preuve d'humanité
marcel jacob et son épouse jacqueline
sont soupçonnés d'être impliqués dans
l'enlèvement de décès du petit garçon de
4 ans retrouvé mort dans la vologne le
16 octobre 1984
les enquêteurs pensent qu'ils pourraient
être les corbeaux qui par leurs lettres
et appels téléphoniques empoisonnait la
vie de la famille mme à cette époque
aujourd'hui à la cour d'appel de dijon
le parquet s'oppose à la modification du
contrôle judiciaire de marcel jacob
pour le procureur général pas question
de compromettre les auditions
respectives des deux époux qui n'ont pas
encore eu lieu
elles se dérouleront les 10 et 17
novembre prochains
deux dates qui attendent avec espoir les
parents du petit grégory il ya un
calendrier qui est prévu ce que nous
avons d'ailleurs souligné on sait que
des auditions interrogatoires sont
prévues
ça ça va être des auditions sur le fond
et c'est effectivement ce qui importe
bien évidemment au parti si fier de
connaître les éléments qui vont être
données dans le cadre de ces auditions
vendredi c'est jacqueline jacob cette
fois qui demandera pour sa part la levée
complète de son contrôle judiciaire et
donc le droit de rentrer chez elle puis
l'après midi vers 16 heures la chambre
d'instruction rendra ses décisions